thank you
[Music]
so here's what the headline reads it
says Myanmar only fans model has been
sentenced to six years in jail
oh [ __ ] you said so far it's gonna sound
happy
is that what you said you said this
one's gonna sound happy you should have
built because it's not gonna be heavy
but we thought this is happy but it will
be heavy oh heavy I was like okay that's
happy yeah it's in Myanmar I kind of got
the idea yeah because I already saw like
what are the fireworks explosions and
stuff there's this girl who's
um she's a model and a former doctor and
uh she's been arrested by the um pretty
much by you you guys know that the
military took over the country right
yeah so she was arrested because of
harming culture and dignity oh I think
uh maybe a few years ago maybe even a
year ago we covered her where she was a
doctor but because of only fans she made
so much she's like well I'm not going to
be a doctor anymore that's her yeah oh
[ __ ] yeah she's been working on stories
here the [ __ ] did you remember that she
report the news arrested and it's
sentenced to six years but also because
I mean she's one of the people there
that's very obviously like in protest of
the current regime and she took uh like
a I guess kind of like a sexy photo
wearing the uniform of the oh they're
making an example out of her oh yeah so
um
that is a story but one of the crazy
things about uh this is that we have a
particular person who's like a long time
JK fan and he's a kid just fan too he is
currently in Myanmar and he for the past
like six months or so has been giving me
like play-by-play things on what's going
on there right now and it's from his
point of view it's crazy so I I sent
this article to him like what do you
think of this I need your feet yeah fact
check this thing and he was like yeah
you know like it's it's a little
sounds crazy but he's like it's a little
harder to kill her because everyone's
looking oh [ __ ] he's like he's like they
kill they kill people all the time that
are not important to anybody there like
if you don't have a reputation and you
know they feel like making you know like
an example out of that area where like
hey this Village there was like a slight
Uprising because they're trying to stamp
out all the rebellions so my dad grew up
in communist China and he says like it's
pretty normal as a kid because like uh
when he was like a little kid that was
when like a chairman mouth took over so
it's like when they're trying to
establish themselves yeah it was normal
to hear like like let's say your
neighbor's like I don't know about the
[ __ ] going on whatever and literally
like the next day soldiers come and just
carry this [ __ ] out they just go
going straight into like the apartment
or whatever they're just carrying
[ __ ] out of there yeah that's
what um that's what our friend has been
saying and uh but you can be a fan of of
Kansas over there without getting
dreaded out that's good
[ __ ]
Steve this is a serious no that I think
that's good that's what I said a huge no
I just think that's good he just wants
to know if your content reached over
there yet you know what now that you
mention it this is the symbol for the
rebellion in Myanmar and it's oh the Boy
Scout scene what the [ __ ] that's Scout's
Honor see I knew you're going with that
so
you is it this yeah
On My Honor I'll do my duty took out of
my country and to obey the Scout Law so
here's the um the crazy thing is our
friend who's currently in Myanmar he's
still trying to figure out how he can um
basically a lot of people trying to
figure out how to leave and stuff but if
they catch you leaving and uh they know
you're a person of importance of any
type then they're gonna stop you so he's
having a problem because he's a doctor
oh he needs to hide the fact that he's a
doctor whoa not only for him when the
regime took over they haven't been doing
any digital
um record keeping so everything's paper
paper so he's been able to um to get as
far as knowing that they don't know he's
a doctor oh there's there's no way they
oh they don't even know he's a doctor
they don't know that's what you're
talking about but if they find out he's
a doctor he's probably gonna go was his
first last name
he's probably that's why um I wanted him
to to you know be on the screen and
telling us but he can't even do that wow
he can't show like that he's is he
trying to leave he's trying to leave can
we help him yeah he needs to get people
out of there with him oh he's a hero
Yeah Tim Kennedy go over there [ __ ]
save everybody can we talk to him and
make a music in one of those AR faces
of like a like a fish's head but it's
something totally inappropriate just a
deep fake of a bark but um it's pretty
crazy getting these play-by-plays from
him because every time I talk to him
like
[ __ ] you're still [ __ ] alive you know
because his whole thing is he's seeing
people getting you know just dis being
deleted you know and I asked him like
Hey I know there's like he tells me so
much every day but I'm like uh can you
sum up like maybe five or six he gave me
ten cool ten eight things
that's going on there that we wouldn't
know is happening
you're an incredible host
[Laughter]
this is incredible one of the craziest
things he said is that like they're not
publicizing how bad it is there because
nobody wants to help like no countries
want to jump in and wrap themselves in
this internal conference yeah yeah
because it's not like uh Russia versus
Ukraine they're not gonna get anything
out of it yeah exactly
I don't know what's going on there so
here's the things that he told me these
are the eight things that are that are
going on that maybe we wouldn't know
social media like Facebook Instagram
Twitter are all banned and you can't
have porn on your mobile phone so these
imagine that when I say these things you
could be instantly killed for breaching
any of these things but a lot of people
still use vpns you know just like China
style but if you actually get caught
using Facebook you could be arrested
whoa but the funny thing is is that the
the regime in power use Facebook exactly
okay on the phone yeah I guarantee you
they're watching tons and then they
tried to make a knockoff face Facebook
out but nobody used it
so that's funny number two no freedom of
speech you can't speak out you can't
talk about politics oh no way um yeah
who would have thought huh
uh yeah the military tries to put fear
in everybody to like you know that's why
the The Killing and the making examples
of people is so strong you know is
because they don't really know who to
Target all the time but they know that
people will see what is it good for the
government to regulate speech
you're [ __ ] it's great we should set
some more people yay number three is uh
government officials and anyone working
under the military can't travel abroad
so that's why like he's saying doctors
nurses Engineers teachers cannot travel
abroad and uh those are the people that
are you know trying to leave but also
they have to hide what they do that's
crazy because they just you're like no
you're too valuable for what we need
you're staying this is like the Obi-Wan
show where it's like how do you get the
Jedi
you wait for the Jedi to reveal
themselves
and like they do [ __ ] up stuff and
then like oh who's gonna be a hero like
that kind of [ __ ] yeah yeah it's crazy
and then they said uh you need a lot of
paperwork and approval to even like make
any Headway and and whether or not you
can leave uh if at any point
throughout the process they figure out
that you're you know against their
regime then that's the end of you
probably number four is
um ongoing Civil War there's shootings
and bombings all the time assassination
of government officials soldiers and
police sound of bomb explosion and
gunshots is just regular wow honestly
when I lived in K-Town 2008 same [ __ ]
I just got used to it I did like
gunshots was like okay sounds kind of
wild though like it was back then car
bombs wow wow not carbons but yeah
definitely definitely gunshots all the
[ __ ] time he said the exhaust yeah
and then you probably can resonate with
this the military uses heavy weapons and
airstrikes to attack small villages they
burn people alive all because they think
the village is hiding uh some of the
resistance forces
Jesus and it doesn't even know it
doesn't matter if they're wrong yeah
like there's no there's nothing you can
do about it uh number five is economy he
said
um the exchange rate that the government
tells you is one US dollar is 2100
Myanmar chaot but the actual rate uh
you're supposed to get 28.50 oh but they
they pull in that extra tax you know
they do that extra tax that's like a 40
tax and he said the GDP has hit an
all-time low but house price and car
price are skyrocketing even the
groceries are expensive and uh and the
leader of this current regime formed an
alliance with Russia and China before
Russia versus Ukraine happened whoa
which is interesting
he thought he could get exports from
Russia but it wasn't that simple
um Russia and China kind of have their
own [ __ ] to handle so they didn't end up
helping the regime
which means less money in the country
for everybody to have
uh number six is banking you can't
withdraw your own money from your own
bank accounts for more than a year now
wait what you put money in for a whole
year since the since the Takeover yeah
like uh it says he said that for a year
now people can't get their money out you
can't even withdraw a penny uh now they
can withdraw around 350 US dollars every
two weeks
yeah and you can spend money Via mobile
banking app which I believe is to keep
it on record on what you're doing it's a
banker's dream honestly that's their
[ __ ] wet dream they have a draw you
can spend and yeah and he said those are
the private Banks he said which was
funny he goes don't even don't let me
start talking about government back he
said these are private Banks I see so
even the private banks have uh sanctions
on them where they're not allowed to let
you take your money out but you can
spend it through the banking account uh
through the app and we shouldn't let
them start because it would probably be
illegal so we gotta be careful they said
you can't withdraw uh your money at all
but if you transfer it to another
account it'll take several days number
seven interestingly is substance abuse
he said even though living expenses are
getting higher illegal drugs are cheaper
than ever whoa the price went down by
half
whoa and the military itself is using
drugs as a distraction on youth
including under 18. uh Myanmar is one of
the top 10 countries in substance
production even before the coup
wow I have no idea some of the [ __ ] I'm
reading for the first time
yeah I'm sure anything synthetic is
probably what do they call that place in
like southeast Asia the Golden Triangle
or something oh it's like the
trafficking thing like opium trade I
wonder if they're like involved
dude yeah he said most of the substances
used here are ecstasy ketamine
amphetamine and meth the majority of of
uh users in the big cities use ecstasy
ketamine and unknown powder that you mix
with water and drink
interesting yeah
which is probably like why the abuse is
so high is because everyone's trying to
cope with what the [ __ ] is happening you
know the spiral and everything and he
said none of the drugs are in their pure
form he said he doesn't use it and he
doesn't even drink alcohol but he can
tell it's so cheap and there's a ton of
side effects and he's seen the side
effects of his own eyes because he's a
doctor wow so they're cutting it with
other stuff he said Walter White would
cry if you saw him
she's getting more depressed as he's
writing this is
somewhere I can VPN Breaking Bad
there's a there's a nationwide curfew
that's in effect from 11 pm to 4 a.m you
cannot uh be seen by cops but police
turn a blind eye on nightclubs and ktvs
what's a KTV it's like a karaoke club
yeah probably because they go there and
he said there's a lot of new ktvs that
open specifically for the drug trade
so there might be some kind of
partnership where they're taking a
little bit of a cut started one or
something yeah mm-hmm yo that's wild
it's okay during Bohemian Rhapsody
that's when it all goes down yeah so he
said if you go out at night you
shouldn't everyone kind of knows already
not to come back home before 4am because
you'll be seen so they'll just stay out
somewhere and then once 4am hits that's
everyone starts walking home
yeah crazy
um and he said the police are in the
drug business
um everybody who's addicted has no
services to help them quit they're just
on it until they till they die uh the
last one he said is new I.T and
telecommunication laws and he said um he
doesn't know the details of it yet
because it's new
but he said the nation is trying to make
these new Cyber laws that uh basically
going to make it so that they have
access to every bit of information and
data in your life and there's nothing
you can do about a breach of your own
data whoa yeah and that's about to come
into effect once the details rolled out
but he's basically saying privacy is
going to be going out the door sounds
like Gmail bro yeah how do they feel
about Kanye or in the all-white the
lives matter
did he mention anything about that I'm
not seeing that what do you think about
lizzo and the flu that's always [ __ ]
up I feel like they're only seeing it
here with idiots like us Brady and
Gisele yeah yeah that's got to be
heartbreaking to them yeah it's pretty
uh it's pretty crazy one of the main
things that he when he we talk about
things and uh I try to keep up with them
every other day or so and um one of the
things he always laments is that
he wishes that
the people had a right to It's Gonna
sound like I'm not a [ __ ] crazy gun
guy but he wishes the citizens could
have had guns before this coup [ __ ]
oh great
because they got them taken away yeah
and so there's nothing they can do now
that the military is in power they're
powerless to stop it all they can do is
try to get out but you can't get out
unless you get your whole family out
because what the [ __ ] is the good so
should they be able to own nukes
laughs
answer the question Ryan that's what you
want huh that's what you want gun guy or
whatever homie wants then uh especially
on their own tank
yeah that's what Biden says
like an F-14 or something like yeah tell
it to the afghanis bro they kicked your
[ __ ] Lily ass [ __ ] I think talking
to him is it's a [ __ ] crazy
eye-opening thing because like you know
when you they make people sound crazy
out here for saying like no I want my
guns because the government takes over
and [ __ ] but like they're no one's
talking about Myanmar because it's a
prime example of that happening and uh
it makes me proud again like not to say
that we have all of the exact same
traits for that to happen here I'm not
saying that I just think it [ __ ]
sucks to hear another guy on another
side wish that he had what we're trying
to stop in a way but that's also why
there's so many veterans that have been
to places like that and that scene that
kind of stuff they stand by the
principal so hard and the problem is
there's like not enough conversation I
think because it's easy to roll off a
guy that has seen [ __ ] like that always
crazy gun freak but he's like no but
he's seen [ __ ] like regimes emerge
from within or it gets toppled or
whatever and he goes and I know how
important it is when the people can
protect themselves you know yeah so Bart
should he get to have his own aircraft
carrier yeah what's next a submarine bar
that's what you're saying obviously that
is exactly what I'm saying one of the
cool things is that uh you know in
talking to him
um I hope one day when he gets out of
there and he ends up somewhere
hopefully nearby we can have him on and
he can really tell the action yeah
seriously uh that's one of the things
I'm always talking about is like telling
the story telling the story but he just
he can't like if they know that he's
could even be talking to you on this
yeah that's the other thing I was
thinking about like Canadians he can as
long as I don't identify him we don't
even need to say where he's talking to
him right yeah he's talking to them but
then that's the thing it's like there's
a whole Rebel [ __ ] Force out there
that are all talking to everybody but
even with them talking out of the
country to all these different people
and if that were to reach a news Outlet
mainstream went out here would not give
a [ __ ] they would tell which is why this
mainstream news channel is reporting to
you almost live I hope this doesn't get
uploaded like four weeks
that does sound really funny but
we are probably closer to a a reliable
source for this than you know something
that would go through the filters you
ever like explain what if you were to
leave like what is like yeah what is
Hospital evacuation plan the sports dad
had to [ __ ] swim like does he have
any kind of plan no he didn't say he
just said that for now it's he's
thinking about his family that's like
the main thing because he doesn't matter
how much you can swim or how high you
can jump It's Like You Gotta [ __ ]
pull your mom and grandma and all this
stuff like what's the point you know
you'll just get 10 feet ahead of them
and and then what you know so that's
really [ __ ] he's in a sticky
situation but he said he's slowly like
you know people around them are getting
out because my my simple mind is like
maybe be a good idea to get into
Thailand first by car because you know
like when you could Traverse just land
and then when you get into more neutral
territory you can take a flight
somewhere else let's try to fly straight
out of the country I think his chances
of duping the system that is not
electronically record keeping and just
kind of having paperwork that makes it a
clean out yeah is his the thing he's
going for most interesting Bart's like I
would just take a lift again
is there jet sweet X over here what's it
take like okay yeah pay for priority get
like he'll come in four minutes he's
like I don't want paper
business class out of there yeah we
should just help this guy out and uh
send him pure drugs you know yeah things
that Walter White would be proud of I'm
pretty sure that's [ __ ] Uber black or
whatever yeah